hello everyone
so yeah so I'm basically going to be
talking about Mono repos in Python today
um so just before we start a quick
introduction about me so my name is Ali
you don't need to pronounce the full
name you can just call me Ali I'm the
CTO at Corridor platforms and what we do
at Corridor is we are basically creating
an IDE to help people write governed and
compliant analytics if you're interested
in that we can talk about it more later
on but let me just go to the actual
topic which is mono repos with python
the the first thing that I always hear
whenever I say mono Repose at least to a
lot of people is hey but isn't mono
rappers the bad thing that you're
supposed to use microservices and
Dockers and kubernetes and all of these
kind of stuff
so let me just get started a little with
what are monoliths what are
microservices and then talk a little
more on monorepers right so monorepo is
basically something that's large and
rigid
so it's a very generic word right it
just means rigidity
and typically when we say monolith
architecture we're talking about
deployments like oh do you want to take
our entire code base and deploy it on a
single server or do we want to run it on
a kubernetes farm or whatever you may
have and deploy it in different ways and
forms
but deployment is good and just changing
your architecture may not mean that you
have like better code or something like
that right like if you had bad code in a
monolith you're just going to have many
pockets of smaller code when you move to
a microservice architecture
so what does that mean like other than
just the deployment aspect you also need
to think about how are you going to
develop your actual application
uh over here you'll see you basically
have two different ways of developing
applications you have a very integrated
way which is I have a folder with all my
code
or you may want to keep a little more
modular like functions classes we've
seen a lot of talks about how to break
up codes and so on so forth and so
that's that's on deployment
and the last one is also on packaging so
you could say I just have like a 5gb
Docker file or Docker container which
has all my dependencies installed or you
could have multiple smaller Dockers or
you're actually installing your packages
or Wheels independently so every time
somebody wants to make one line of code
change they don't need to download the
entire internet right which is the
typical problem with npm packages
so monolith can be in different aspects
whether it's deployment packaging or
even development and we're going to be
more focusing on the development aspect
right so whenever we talk about Mono
repos it has nothing to do as much with
packaging or deployment it's more to do
with how are you going to develop and
organize your code in a clear clearer
way
now let's go to advantages the main
advantage right is that when you have a
monolith application you may say
monolith is bad but when you start
developing something you don't know how
to break it up you don't know how to
make it modular especially because
requirements change right like let's say
we started Corridor about five years ago
for the first one year 80 of the code
just kept changing every month
that's kind of how it is but monoliths
have the advantage of just saying
everyone understands everything that's
happening within the application just
because everything is in one place you
don't need to know anything too
complicated you just understand what's
happening overall
so in general developers can contribute
to any part of the code easier you don't
have to like Chase around things you can
reuse and refactor codes quite easily
and also deploying and everything is
much easier with monoliths right
it's just the old school simple way of
doing things so I would actually
encourage everyone if you're working on
a new project don't think about
microservices so at least at the start
start with just writing your code and
then you'll see how the structure
evolves
well let's also talk about the issues of
monolith so the main difference is as
soon as a part of your application needs
to be slightly different
that's when you have problems what do I
mean by slightly different
so let's say there's a particular API or
a particular machine learning model that
you have who just needs to frequently
change
right is because of market conditions
every month you need to update it or
whatever it is
or there is something which which is
much slower than the other aspects so
all of these are things which imply that
your code base is normally uniform but
one part just needs to change quite
frequently
and sometimes it's even like tooling so
we saw a lot of talks about rust and
Python and so on so forth so many times
it's just that something is really slow
I need to rewrite it addressed do I
create a separate repo for a device use
it in the same repo all of these kind of
issues
and can you guess what the solution for
all these issues are
well it's in the title it's basically
model repose
so one wrappers are basically here to
help with some of these issues but again
I just want to be like the disclaimer
over here is
you go into something and you think that
it's you know the best thing that you've
seen in the world but typically that's
never the case
so monitor is a great but then they also
have their own issues and you need to
know when to use monodepers in the right
way
so let's just maybe talk about what are
the standard maintenance tasks that any
maintainer needs to manage so all of
these are familiar right like install
format linting testing packaging Etc
what you'll see is that a bunch of these
tasks if there is one team which is
working on the entire code base let's
say your monolith code base and now you
want to start branching out right you
want to say oh I want to write something
and rest as an example
the image at nature is all right I'm
going to create a new repository for it
and then I'm going to work on my rest
and you may say oh this thing needs like
a Jupiter extension or something like
that so I need to start writing some
JavaScript code now so let me create a
new repository for it and I'm going to
start writing JavaScript in a separate
repository and so on so forth right
but let's say if you're doing formatting
right
if you have multiple repositories of
python and each of them let's assume
you're using black or something like
that to format your code you typically
want to pin your version of black right
so that people are not formatting
differently in different parts of your
company or teams
now just imagine going to like 20 30 40
different repositories and going and
updating the version of black every
single time there's a new change it gets
very painful so you may think in the
starting that it's easy to manage two
three for repositories but over time it
becomes very difficult and can just
become a lot more time consuming and
that's when you can have two solutions
you either say let me go and that's what
we had to decide at Corridor a while
back is do we want to create now Bots
which will go and synchronize all our
repositories which is a solution too or
do you want to just reevaluate the
correct structure that you want to use
based on your current understanding of
your organization
so a bunch of tasks which are which are
difficult
uh when one team is working on multiple
reports the second category of things
over here is
when you have multiple repositories
which are very tightly coupled like
let's say a package one which really
heavily depends on package too it could
just be let's say a bunch of apis which
are meant for machine learning
deployment and so you have a bunch of
machine learning models which need to be
deployed in those apis
now every time that you're going to
deploy the API it's impossible to test
or deploy the API like an integration
test without the actual machine learning
models so therefore they're pretty
tightly integrated one cannot really
exist without the other in this case at
least from a deployment perspective so
therefore packaging deployment all of
these activities are difficult when
multiple projects are tightly coupled
and you have different repositories for
each of the projects
so what does that mean so like we're
going to talk about the standard
questions right like when why how to use
monodepers
so when should mono wrappers be used
based on everything we just saw right
now
if there is the same team working on
majority of the code base agree
right because the team needs to know all
the different kinds of dependencies or
code changes they may need to do not
only in their project but also other
projects
if your your projects are very tightly
coupled like one cannot work without the
other situations over there again one
other powers are great right so there
are normally two ways that projects work
they basically integrate tightly or
there's like a handshake you know like
how apis work as an example so you have
a handshake of how two projects can work
together
so if they're very tightly coupled then
mono rivers are again good for that and
the last one is more of a realistic
situation like you know you could say
that oh my entire team is my entire
company of thousand people who work very
cohesively and they're all working on
different projects and all these and all
of them are fairly related to each other
but realistically if you're going to be
using tools in the open source like git
GitHub Etc you cannot really be using I
don't know 10 GB of code put like your
entire company's worth of code inside
one repository and there are just real
life considerations that also come into
the picture right unless you want to
rewrite git which is
a project in itself
so
typically when you're using a monitor
app or the other three things to
consider the team the projects and also
the tools that you have available
and the next question is audience which
is who is going to be impacted by the
monodepo like if you made a decision of
using monorail who's going to be
impacted by it
so there are three three folks right
like first is the end user there should
be zero impact on the end user because
monodepo is just a way of structuring
your code base so if you're saying that
if I move one line on the top and my
entire application breaks you have
bigger issues to deal with I don't think
monorepose is your answer for that so
end users should just never be impacted
that's number one
number two is developers so
you know as developers we're used to a
particular way of working like how to
install a package how to clone multiple
things and so on so forth
and this kind of becomes a little more
complex especially with monorepos in the
current way the tools are set up in
GitHub and so on so forth access is a
major concern that a lot of people have
you know like if I put everything all my
company scored into a single repo should
everyone have access to all the code all
the points in time so things like that
just need to be considered about how
developers will be impacted when you're
moving to monitors
and the last one is CI environments
which is actually the most common reason
why I see people moving to a mono repo
saying that you know we deployed
something and our entire build broke
because another component was not
deployed at the same time or the latest
version was not used in tightly coupled
projects all of these kind of things
so you just need to realize who do you
want to impact should it like end users
should never be impacted but CI and
developers who should be impacted
and the last one the most important one
is how should the code be structured
with the Mona refers so the first
options there are a few options here so
we just go through it the first option
is just have all the code in
subdirectories so let's say if I have a
folder for ML a different folder for
reports Etc you can just have all your
code for ML and ml all look all the code
for reports and reports in a previous
environment this could be a separate
repository this could be a separate
repository kind of thing right but let's
say all your code is just in a folder
which is then being pushed to get
the second one is have separate packages
for each part of your code so you'll see
that the Pi Project the terminal the
setup.py Pi Project at Armor which has
been added over there is saying that ml
is just an independent entity or
independent python package which can be
then be deployed separately packets
separately Etc same for reports and so
on so forth
and when you have separate packages for
each part that's when you normally think
about should I keep the packages in this
in the same repository or should I keep
it in
a single Repository
so this is basically the the decisions
that you have to make about how the code
should be structured and two of these
lead to the fact that you're going to be
creating a mono Network because if you
have a single directory it has to be a
model repo like you have to commit it
together or if you're keeping all the
packages in one one Repose again because
all right so let's maybe just take some
examples to understand this whole
structure and all of these a little
better
so the the most basic thing right like
the steps that you need to move towards
the mono repo or start using a monorepo
is number one move all your code to a
single repo or if it's already in a
single repo just structure it out in the
form that you want for long term
and here is where you can decide the two
options that we spoke about integrated
monopo which is everything in one folder
or multiple packages in the Morning
Report
and the second one is who needs to be
impacted we spoke about CI and
developers so that's a colony that needs
to be made and a lot of people have just
come back and told me that you know I I
love mono repos it will help my CI
environment and so on so forth but
my developers don't want to move right
so there is there are options of just
managing your monodepo structure so that
your developers have minimal impact or
no impact at all
and the last one most important one over
here is the tooling that's required to
implement this so there are different
tools and we'll go into some examples of
these tools but you just need to
understand how these tools work and the
benefits that they provide
all right so the first point that we
talked about right which is moving all
the code to a single repo there's a
decision to be made over there about
packaged or integrated so let's talk
about that a little more
over here the the general thought
process with integrated and packaged is
first of all dependencies
in an integrated environment because you
just have a folder and then different
files using each other import statements
are the way that one file can be used in
another file so your most basic unit is
a file so in an integrated setup you'll
normally say I want to test this file or
I want to modify this file you don't
really care as much about packages and
how it's going to get deployed you just
care about the files that you need to
modify in a package based on the other
hand it's more like the dependencies are
managed by requirements the txt or
etc.py just saying
which packages does this particular
package depend on and so on so forth
so the the single fundamental unit in
integrated is a file whereas in a
package based it's a package
and tooling so in an integrated
environment typically because you don't
differentiate between oh this folder is
for package or project one this is for
project two and so on so forth you
normally have a single set of tools that
you use for all of them like let's just
take an example of poetry or you know
pip or something like that you're
basically going to be using the same
installer for for the entire folder
right whenever you're managing
requirements and so on so forth but in
package base because you've like divided
them into separate packages you can
choose your tools per package so if you
have an existing setup where you know
different teams are using different
repositories and each of them have their
own package like one uses black one uses
rough Etc it's much easier to move
towards package based because every
package can just reside independently
and still work in the same way inside
your monorepo
yeah so migrating is basically not as
easy with integrated because just a
whole different way of thinking if you
have existing set of poly repo packages
but in package base it's a lot easier
because it's just the same setup
and the last one probably the most
important for folks who are more
interested in the CI part is caching so
remember we said that the single unit is
at a file level right and most of the
tools that we'll talk about the biggest
thing that happens when you move from
poly wrappers to monorepos is
let's say you have test cases right you
have different packages five packages
each of them have let's say a thousand
test cases which are written out every
time you're submitting a pull request
you don't want all 5000 test cases to
run if I just made one line code change
in package one I just want maybe those
thousand maybe even lesser than thousand
test cases to run for that one package
right in a polyrup setup that was
happening automatically right because I
would push to one repository and then
the test case the Thousand test cases
for that repo would let Etc
so when you go to a monorepostructure
the biggest question is how do you
figure out what are the affected changes
like which files or which packages are
affected and only run the test cases the
formatting whatever other CI processes
you have just for that portion and
that's a cool thing about integrated
reports right like it's like even if I
go and modify one file
it can figure out that don't even run
thousand test cases only these five test
cases need to be run for that file
so all the dependencies because they're
at a file level it's basically like
saying every file is a package of its
own so you can just test that one unit
which is that one file
so integrated setups are a lot more
efficient in general
but package based setups are a lot more
intuitive because that's how we normally
think about things like you know what
gets deployed there's a wheel for every
package Etc so that's kind of the
difference between caching and
integrated and package waste
all right so there are three there are
three types of mono wrappers that we're
going to be talking about over here the
first one is just purely CI based which
is saying developers don't need to be
impacted just the CI environment matters
right I just want to speed up my CI
which is Travis GitHub actions whatever
you're using over there
so over here first of all you can
structure your code in CI based
environment sector you can actually use
either one like package or integrated
really doesn't matter so you can use
whichever approach you want to do
and
then you need to create some
configuration in your CI tool like let's
say if it's GitHub actions or Circle CI
Etc on what are the affected changes
remember we spoke about the biggest
issue in monodepos is the affected
changes and typically most CI tools have
a way of dictating this like let me just
take the example of GitHub action so
let's say if I have the reports
integrated tests I can give a
configuration of the paths parameter to
GitHub actions to say whenever these
folders or these files are getting
modified only then run my integrated
test cases right so that's how myci
environment knows which test cases to
run depending on which part of the
monorepo is being modified
so that's pretty simple right like this
is this is like the most basic version
where developers are not getting
impacted in any way you could have
multiple packages or you could even take
let's say your entire monolith so let's
assume this Django packages is an
example so you can just take your entire
Django application it has different
modules so that's kind of like an
integrated setup and you can just test
different parts of your Django
application or so whenever you're
pushing into a CR environment
so that's pretty much it right because
you don't need to do much it's just a CI
that gets optimized
the next one is package based monodepo
so in the package based Corner repo
you'll see first you need to structure
your code and it needs to be package
based hence the name
so when you're structuring is it as a
package base remember that it's like you
could have multiple folders and there
are different folders with specific uh
you know packages like Pi Project or
setup.py however you want to package it
it can be anything it can you know I'm
giving the example a python over here
but it could also be an npm package it
could be a maven package whatever you
want it doesn't really matter
so different packages which have
different languages or different tools
and then you need to decide on which
tool you want to use
typical uh so a quick note over here is
that I found that the python tooling for
package based mono repos is not that
strong like poetry has a bunch of stuff
which they're trying to do with poetry
workspace but that's still not released
or they're still creating plugins for it
but one of the best tools that I've seen
for package based monorepers and this
tool is language agnostic so it's NX for
those of you are familiar with it it's
basically very commonly used in the
JavaScript ecosystem for like angular
and react applications next and so on
so NX has some pretty generic ways of
how it manages monorepos which can also
be used for Python and that's the
example that I'm going to be talking
about which is the first decide on a
tool initialize it using whatever
command is there in that tool let's say
NX in it
and then you need to configure the tool
and that's like the hardest part I guess
so let's just talk about this a little
more right first of all let me go into
uh
into a project that I have open over
here so here's an example NX Library let
me just close a few things yep so here's
an example NX Library you have an
nx.json which is the core file which
just tells NX how to get installed and
which version to use and stuff like that
and in that you have some things about
cachable operators operations and stuff
which we can come back to and we'll also
talk about default base but along with
the nx.json file you'll see that I have
in this case two packages or two
libraries
and inside reports I have something
called a project.json so project.json is
how NX finds what are all the projects
in your monodepo whether it's libraries
applications they have some different
categories but every project or Json is
considered as a single unit or a single
package in NX
and here you can Define different
targets so NX has a very general thing
like when I just run a bash command
which is the Run commands approach so
you have different targets for how to do
an install how to let's say run your
formatters how to kind of the formatters
your test cases with pi test and so on
so forth and you can Define each of
these tasks for this package
the cool thing about this is that over
here I've written run commands for
python but my other project let's say
data lake or reports or something else
or ml or something else could be using a
completely different language and NX
doesn't care about that so over here we
could be having like an npm command or a
Java command Scala rust whatever you
want like cargo Etc different kinds of
commands can be here and NX doesn't is
pretty agnostic to the language that it
uses in this case
and you'll notice that along with the
Target or yeah along with these targets
or tasks you also say what does it
depend on and what are the inputs
so you can change your tasks saying that
oh before you run test cases you need to
build your application so only then you
can test it
so you can and NX will then realize that
if you're trying to run the test command
it will automatically run the build and
the install commands before that so it
really handles your task pipelines in a
pretty clean way
and the second one is inputs where it
says what are all the files that that
this command uses so let's say if I'm
doing Pi test I care about the source
files and the test files right if I ever
change any of my source files I want
pytest to run again if I ever change any
of my testing files I won't fight or
even the configuration files and so on
so forth I may want pi test to run again
so using the inputs NX basically knows
the whole affected the thing that we are
talking about in the CI environment
where you have to manually provide each
of your files basically it's kind of
similar but over here you have just some
a little more elegant way of defining
which files matter for this task
what this means is
in your CI environment and we'll go into
an example of this if anyone goes and
modifies a DOT py file that's a source
files right like source files are
defined on the top over here anything in
this folder is considered a source file
so if any developer is going and
modifying a file in this folder
in your CI environment you should be
running the test command and NX figures
that out for you
NX also has a lot of caching operations
which I haven't gone into like the
cachable operations over here so they
even have this whole Cloud solution
where even as a developer if I'm running
something if none of the inputs have
changed then it adjusts cached the
results for me and it's pretty elegant
and cool I'd encourage you read up more
about it after the talk
so that's how NX works you have an
nx.json you have a project.json in the
project.json you define your targets and
then you talk about all these
dependencies and so on so forth and
project.json
a quick note here is that this could get
cumbersome over time right like let's
say if I have Pi test I need to Define
every single folder which can be a pain
so on so forth
there are there are plugins in NX
available to like especially again in
the JavaScript world to go and scrape
your code base and figure out the
structure of your code and figure out
these configurations for you
in Python also there used to be a plugin
but it's not maintained right now so I
haven't talked about it nor am I using
it because it's been like three years
since they released or something
so at least in in my team we've created
a few packages which hopefully will open
source in the future but yeah so that's
basically how NX works you can have
better executors which understand your
code base but for python it does not
exist right now
now once you've configured your tool and
NX knows what it's doing or who knows
what your monorepo is structured now you
need to start documenting and start
using this tool right so here's where
the benefits come through you have three
most common things that you would want
to do with monorepos and there are many
more but I've just taken three so you
want to run all your test cases on all
your packages
right so you can just say NX run on all
packages all my test cases and again
remember that the tests can be in any
language it can run Java test cases test
cases C test cases python test cases all
with this one command
then you have you want to run something
on a single package so you could say run
on the reports run only test cases for
the reports package so you can do that
and this is the most interesting one at
least for me which I was describing in
terms of the whole caching operations
which is NX tries to figure out if
something is whatever is affected
only run the test cases for whatever is
affected
and now you may ask hey what is affected
even mean so you can define that
in the nx.json you'll see that the
affected is basically the default base
is the main branch so affected over here
would be take the main branch see all
the files that have been modified since
your main branch your latest comment in
your main branch and only run test cases
for whatever has been modified so now if
I create a feature branch and then I'm
trying to do various code development
over there I can just run the test cases
for whatever I modified and NX can
figure that out pretty neatly
so that's basically what NX does right
so that's how a package based setup
typically looks like
let's go into the integrated monodepo
so the integrated monorepo is the one
which is a little more non-intuitive so
I'm going to spend maybe a little more
time on that
in an integrated setup you want to
structure your code as an integrated
structure so let's let's talk about this
um
and yeah
over here you'll see that I have a
folder called Corridor and I just have
different folders for all my packages
and just writing the py files over there
so you'll notice you know there's no
setup.py no Pi Project or terminal and
all of these kind of things just think
of it like literally one large code base
pretty much your so if you're going from
the monolith world where you have one
large code base integrated may actually
be easier as compared to moving package
based so it kind of depends on where
you're going to move from
but in the data Lake I have all these
files
and in any one of them I I'm actually
importing things from let's say the data
Lake component and so on so forth right
now what is where do are these
dependencies and packages can I come
from so remember that we said in an
integrated setup every file is
considered a module or a package
which means that this histogram.pheep.py
is considered as a basic unit and a
package
you can even deploy histogram.py just as
a separate Docker container or whatever
you may want
right it's just a completely independent
unit you may want to test it you may
want to deploy it you may want to
package it in completely different ways
and
but the thing that you know a lot of
people ask me is what does that mean so
does that mean that for every file I
need to write a requirements.txt and so
on so forth well not exactly using your
import statements you can normally
figure out what your dependencies and so
on so forth are and there are a lot of
tools which help you especially with
integrated setups to manage this code
base in a clearer way
so let's just go through that
so in terms of tooling you have a lot
more options for integrated setups
because that's normally the place when
people say monorepers that typically
mean integrated mono repos
which again not everyone needs to go
there I think it's only required for
some very specific cases but integrated
mono repos is the norm
and pants basil Buck are all the common
tools that exist over here I'm going to
be talking about pants a little more
just because pants is you know like
written in Python much easier to use
with python it's like python native mono
refers
um and basil buck and so on are more for
other languages but can also be used in
Python and language agnostic in general
so first of all you install pants can be
as simple as just a shell script that
you run
and again configuring the tool so here's
where things become a little
non-intuitive like when you run a pants
tailor command it'd be like in pants
everything works with this configuration
file called the build file build is a
simple tomml file nothing else so let's
go and take a quick example of it
so yeah so you'll see something of that
but basically a typical build file is
just uh I'm sorry it's actually not a
terminal file scratch that it's just a
file where you can Define your
configurations for pants and pans
configurations are like functions in
Python they try to keep it very similar
to a python syntax where you can Define
what exactly is in your
uh
well the build file basically defines
the structure of your mono repo as well
as it can I'm going to take a different
example just because that one is very
minimal so let's say I'm in the data
Lake setup right I can Define all the
test cases inside this folder using a
python test
keyword the python test basically takes
anything which ends with underscore
test.py and defines that as all the test
cases for the data Lake folder
you can even have resources so let's say
if I have a CSV file you can Define that
as a resource like data files and so on
so forth and you can have even source
code which is any dot py file and you'll
notice over here that my py files are
reading my CSV file so therefore there's
a dependency saying my py file requires
the CSV file to run correctly so you
will again notice similar to what we
were doing in project.json but just in a
different way we are defining the
different components or every file is
being mapped to a type whether it's a
test case a resource a source file Etc
and these types help pants to understand
your repository a lot better
once it understands it you can try
figuring out things like what is
affected
for example let's again assume that I
want to run test cases right so let's
say I go and modify my CSV file and go
and change some data inside the CSV file
when I push this out into a CI
environment and so on so forth and I
tell parents tell me whatever has been
affected and run all the test cases it
will figure out that
this CSV file is being used in these set
of python sources these set of python
sources are being tested by these set of
python tests so therefore all the tests
in this folder need to be rerun because
the CSV file has been modified
so very similar to what the project.json
in NX was doing but at a file level as
compared to a project level right so the
entire point of all these configurations
just summarizing is for the tool to
understand the contents of your monorepo
and along with all this stuff about you
know like how to understand the contents
of the monorepo you also have
configurations for how to actually
distribute package and so on so forth so
there's like a python distribution setup
which says I want to create a wheel a
wheel file for python
and for this you can use some setup.py
which already exists so you can embed a
setup tool set up a py
and also you can say what are all the
what are all the files that need to be
present inside this wheel file so you
can essentially con like you you don't
use things like the Pi Project and so on
so forth again you could use Pi Project
and tell pants to read from your Pi
Project so that is also doable
but pants needs to know how to create an
executable or a wheel file in this case
from your Repository and the cool thing
here is right like because I just have
the entire folder structure like you
know I could have thousands of folders
at any point in time I can just say hey
I want to build a file over there and I
want to create this as a separate Docker
file so let's assume that you are
deploying your entire project as a
monolith all this file right everything
put into a single Docker file and then
just getting deployed you can suddenly
just say oh in this particular portion
over here I want to add a build file I
want to create a separate wheel from it
and then I can start doing different
things in the wheel and there's no code
changes that you do at all because in an
integrated setup everything is at a file
level so you really don't need to worry
about changing your code moving all your
code from one place into another place
none of that stuff your code Remains the
Same and then pans can understand what
needs to be packaged and deployed and
there are many other functions you can
even deploy to Lambda and all of these
kind of things directly from pants
so that's basically about configuring
things and in the build file is where
you see most of the configurations that
are present
and coming to the final user usage and
documentation so that's where
uh again in pants if you want to run on
all your projects and
not over here that we don't talk about
projects we just talk about files so if
you want to run all your files test
cases you can just say pans test colon
colon it'll run all test cases in your
entire so all 5000 test cases in the
previous example we'll just run
you can run it on a single file again
not we never talk about I want to run
test cases for a wheel or a Wonderland
test cases for a particular package it's
always at a file level because
everything over here is all about files
and you can also say changes like the
the equivalent to the affected command
that we had in NX so you can say I want
pans to run all the test cases of
everything that is changed since the
main branches last commit so same
thought process same thought processes
NX it takes the last commit figures out
all your changed files and runs the test
cases
so just just repeating one point which
is like the most important point with
integrated right it's integrated is a
lot more efficient because you don't
need to run thousand test cases every
time you're pushing something in one
package you may only run five test cases
or ten test cases
but it's just also may not be the most
intuitive if you're coming from a
package based mono rep poly repo stage
where you have multiple repos or
multiple packages so just depends on
which direction you want to move your
code base into
so yeah I think that's about it uh just
to summarize everything we spoke about
uh you have monolith architecture and
you have Micro Services I think
monorepos is like a good segue which
helps you structure out your code
amongst both of them and again you don't
think of monoliths as a bad thing like a
lot of people just think of it as a
taboo it's kind of like the go-to
function right like nobody should use go
to just use for loops
so monoliths is I think useful in in the
right places which is normally in the
start of a project when you still don't
know how your code is going to evolve
once you start seeing some structures
you can move towards monorepose and when
you're in a mono repo setup you can
actually still move towards
microservices quite easily so therefore
it's a good segue into structuring your
code in a better way
and monorepos are great when you have a
single team working on all the projects
that you're working on and all the
projects are linked to each other in
some form or the other so in that setup
model refers are great if you have
multiple teams who don't care about the
other team's code you're probably better
off just keeping separate repos so that
they don't break each other's code AS
compared to trying to help each other
and if only CI is a concern then don't
bother with changing your developers you
know like training your developers to
start running new commands like getting
all my developers to change from pip
install to NX install was just a big
effort in itself because no one
remembers and no one does it how much of
a documentation you write
so if you don't need to move your
developer change your developer
experience just don't change it and just
focus on your CI
and the last one is package based model
repos are easy to understand and
integrated mono repos are just a lot
more efficient mainly because they have
a unit of a file
right that's about it I think the
references and so on so forth you can
take a look at from the slides later on
[Applause]
thank you ollie for your great talk and
thanks to all of you for your questions
we will go to them now
could you briefly elaborate on the role
of git sub modules in the ecosystem of
monorepos
so I
uh good question on git sub modules so I
kind of think as get well let me just go
one step backward
I think that when you're trying to
structure your code you can have all
your code in one repo or all the code in
multiple reports when you're using
multiple reports you could be using
different kinds of approaches of
integrating your repos in some form or
the other a very common example is just
using a gitbot right people have just
written their own GitHub Bots which will
go and synchronize all the CI tests or
the dependencies across all the things
like contact Forge is a very good
example which I really like if for those
of you who use condo Forge they
basically have a CI and a bot which will
go and update all the packages in condo
Forge if anything needs to be changed
consistently
some modules are just another way of
synchronizing multiple repositories I
think they have their own benefits like
the biggest issue which I have with uh
get some modules is
because it's at a commit level and not
at a branch level
every time somebody makes a change and
let's say the main branch somebody has
to go and remember that they need to
update the commit
in your parent repo a largest gets like
frustrating at some points but again I I
remember that there's no there's no
one-size-fits all these are all just
different approaches and what works for
you just works for you and that's cool
which is different ways of managing your
code base
if you have hundreds of comets from
other developers every day on a mono
repo how do you keep on repo and think
when you work on it
well if you have I mean I think the most
standard practice over there is just
pull every day or pull every half a day
um and just rebase right so I'm not sure
about it kind of depends on what the
structure of your organization is maybe
and if somebody asks the question from
you or maybe you want to elaborate so I
can get a more pointed answer but at
least I typically recommend feature
branches to be very short that you
should not be having more than 10 to 15
commits and every commit of in in at
least Iron Force every commit should not
have more than 20 lines of code change
so a very small atomic changes that can
be quickly merged is what I would
generally recommend with Git I know
different people have different
preferences so it just depends on what
kind of setup you're using
next question in the package based
monorepo how would you add ml as a
dependency of reports roughly speaking
poetry at Pi PML versus poetry at local
ml
oh okay so the uh so the question let me
just rephrase that question is if I have
package based repo how does one package
know that they need to depend on another
package
right because I can have package one
package two like let's say ml is being
used in the reports so whenever we
install reports I guess the ml package
also needs to be installed so remember
that in a package based monitor for you
every package can use their own tooling
so if you're using poetry you just
Define it however poetry does it if
you're using requirements files you can
do a minus E and then the path
so whatever tool you're using to manage
that particular package can just be like
just the same is no difference
or the benefit over that is that you
know exactly what folder structure it's
at
right so let's say if you have two
different packages and two different
repos You're Expecting the developer to
clone two things
and then install this package in this
case virtual environment
and that can be different commands for
different people because you know
different people clone things with
different names and stuff like that but
in a modern app where it's a lot more
structured so you can actually hard code
the path in your requirements file and
there's a very good plugin which got
created in poetry very recently which
says if you're using a relative path
then whenever you're packaging it change
it to a an actual package in Pi Pi so
stuff like that can be used but it all
depends on the packaging manager and the
yeah and the tools that you're using in
that package
would you oh uh why is dependency
management easier in monorepers an
example in different packages have
different dependencies
well I think the I kind of answered that
in the previous question but
it's just that dependency management is
a lot easier because let's say if I'm
using a tool and I'm expecting or let's
say if I'm using Jupiter right a good
example for everyone
when you are using Jupiter there are
multiple dependencies that are present
and you need to make sure they're all
synchronized
like your Jupiter core your IPI widgets
your Jupiter lab Jupiter notebook server
titlets all of these need to you need to
make sure that all the dependencies are
matching
if they're all being maintained by the
same team and they're very tightly
coupled that you know like let's say
package version 5.x needs five point x
from another package
then with the monorepo you can just make
sure you're always using 5.x
if you go back in time like let's say a
month or year a year earlier all your
packages are getting consistently
downgraded to four point x
so these kind of things must become a
lot easier with the monorepo because if
all your packages are tightly coupled
they're just moving in the same Pace I
guess in terms of your release Cycles
even when you're deploying you can just
deploy everything like you know 4.3
all of them just get applied as 4.3 you
don't have one at four point three one
at four point two one at four point ten
and then developers need to like figure
out oh which versions are actually
compatible then you need to have a
support Matrix of what are compatible it
just becomes a lot more headache right
so that's why mono Depots are easier to
manage for Developers
there are so many more questions but I
think we have just time for one more I
think if the people have questions they
can come to you yeah yeah I'll be around
the entire day so you can just catch me
anytime okay last question what's your
stance on using git sub modules
as I said I personally don't like it
somebody else
just because I need to keep
synchronizing my other repositories to
like if git sub module was at a tag
level or at a branch level I think I
would have loved it
but sadly it's at a commit level where
you need to give the exact commit ID
that you need to update so before you
know I started even researching into
monoraptors we were using sub modules
and when I was maintaining I am normally
very clear about what needs to be
updated Etc it's easy for me to go and
remember I need to update this and this
process and this process but again how
much ever you document stuff right the
next person like when the release
manager changed for our company
the entire thing was messed up
so because of stuff like that I think
gitsub module has Oddities and therefore
unless you're really comfortable with it
I generally try avoiding using it
again very rare scenarios where it's
useful but I prefer either having like a
bot which will then go and synchronize
all my sub modules to make sure it's at
a the branch commits are the same or
just moving to a mono repo setup
okay thank you for sharing your ideas
with us to all of you have a great day
[Applause]